So, we've learned a little bit more about the relationship
between age and friend count. And we did that using
conditional means. We'll return to these two variables later and
we'll see the relationship to a third variable in less than
five. But for now, let's see how more used a
slightly different approach to pair a histogram to summarize her raw
data. So here's an example of how we paired raw
data with summary data. So, here we have these scatter plots,
where we're showing people's raw guesses of their perceived
audience size against their actual audience size. And you
can see they all fall below the perfect accuracy
line. So people underestimate. But it's still kind of hard
to get it the big picture from these scatter
plots and so, we have some histograms to capture
more summary data. In this case, these two histograms
show how much people over or underestimated their audience size.
So here on the left, at the 0 mark on the x axis, that's how many people
guessed their audience size perfectly. If they had
a lighter color blue, those are people that underestimated
their audience. So you can kind of see
how many people underestimated their audience by about 25%,
versus 50%, versus 75% and so on. The
darker blue are people who overestimated their audience size.
And you can just see from the
chart far fewer people overestimated their audience size.
If you look on the right side of these summary plots, this is for people's over
underestimations when you ask them about the
whole month. How many people in general do
you think see your post? And you can
see that people don't underestimate quite as badly.